hey i'm booboo stewart and i'm here with
buzzfeed to take a short quiz to find
out which combination
of twilight and disney characters i am
let's find out
[Music]
first how would your bffs describe you
loyal creative reliable impulsive honest
i would say creative choose a sidekick
we have a
genie from aladdin mushu from mulan olaf
from frozen
flounder from the little mermaid to mom
and pumbaa from the lion king
vanilla p van schweetz from wreck-it
ralph i'm gonna go with mushu i
he is he's the man uh choose a class to
attend
how to take a great hashtag selfie tree
climbing 101
street fighting in physics the art of
edm
pop music and feminism vampires
werewolves a history it's definitely
between tree climbing 101 street
fighting
business i'm gonna go street fighting
choose the disney princess that you
vibe with the most ariel from the little
mermaid mulan from mulan
uh tiana from the princess and the frog
belle from beauty and the beast
jasmine from aladdin uh rapunzel from
tangled oh i love tangled so much
i really like that movie but the little
mermaid is so good too i love the song
part of your world that is my favorite
disney song
all right ariel from the little mermaid
okay choose a series to binge watch
game of thrones brooklyn nine-nine
shit's creek
stranger things on my block julie and
the phantoms
i can't choose the show that i'm in um
stranger things
because my family and i actually binge
watched stranger things we watched the
whole third season
in one sitting uh which twilight
character would you trust with a secret
rosalie charlie swan
renasce may leia clearwater jasper i
would say rosalind
she seems like she could keep a pretty
solid secret there finally
pick a song uh to sing it karaoke mama
mia by
savage by megan the stallion mr bright
side by the killers i love that song
toxic by britney spears no scrubs like
dlc or human rights by queen uh mamma
mia definitely
you got alice cullen and tinkerbell from
peter pan
like alice you're intelligent bold and
oh so fierce
you're quick on your feet and always
prepared for whatever life throws at you
like tinkerbell you're loyal
strong-willed and a little bit impulsive
your friends value your opinions because
you tend to always be right
i love that so much i'm tinkerbell and
alice thank you so much buzzfeed for the
wonderful quiz and you can check out my
new movie
let him go out in theaters november 6th
thank you so much
[Music]
you